what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be delving
deep
into the warped world of boku no hero's
current
war arc did deku just put himself
at risk of losing one for all
is shigaraki now a prisoner inside his
own body and how does nana shimura
tie into all of this oh and is bakugo
going to be okay after sustaining a very
serious injury at the hands of shigaraki
let's talk about it but first up this
past
week we reached 1 million subscribers
here on the anime opera channel that
is incredible honestly it doesn't even
feel real
i want to give my most sincere thank you
to each and every one of you who took
the time to subscribe and click that
little notification bell
i can't believe that over a million of
you guys enjoyed our content enough to
do that
and i am very humbled and grateful to
each and every one of you
thank you so much finally of course this
video will contain boku no hero manga
spoilers we're talking about the latest
events in the story
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
as you will recall the previous
installment of the story
ended with a massive cliffhanger both
endeavour
and bakugou were pierced by shigaraki's
black and red spikes
and both of their injuries looked pretty
serious
if the newest chapter started off with
some kind of flashback or if the focus
had switched to another location
i would have been pissed but thankfully
horikoshi was merciful this time and the
action picks up right where it left
off after being pierced by shigaraki
bakugo is covered in blood
but he still manages to call out to deku
to tell him not to go playing hiro
by himself this might sound like bakugo
is being his usual competitive self
but in reality bakugou is saying this
because he is worried about deku pushing
himself too far
this time it's not competition that's
driving bakugo
it's genuine concern for his friend and
he was willing to sacrifice his own life
to protect
deku honestly that was pretty
heartwarming
bakugou has definitely come a long way
and hopefully he continues to develop as
a character
unless he dies of course meanwhile the
barbecued shigeraki appears to be
fighting
with himself and it seems like he is
saying stop it
to someone it's safe to assume that he's
saying this to all for one
since in the last chapter all for one
straight up to control of shigaraki's
body
officially all for once said that he did
it to help shigaraki survive this fight
but as i mentioned in my previous boku
no hero video
a few of us have been suspicious of all
for one for a very long time
and we believe that he might be trying
to take over shigaraki's body so that he
himself can use it
as his new vessel when deku finally
processes
what just happened to bakugo he
absolutely loses it
thankfully shoto is able to grab bakugou
in midair and fly him away from
shigaraki and presumably to a safer
location
but even though bakugou appears to have
been taken out of harm's way
we still don't know how bad his injuries
were since the spikes
pierced his torso clean through some
vital organs
might have been damaged it did kind of
look like bakugou had blood coming out
of his mouth
which would suggest that one of his
lungs was injured
but we can't know for sure because that
blood around his mouth might have been
splattered from his torso wound
it's possible that he got lucky and the
spike missed all of his vital organs
and that is probably what happened
because i do not think that bakugou is
going to die
i think that horikoshi just wanted to
scare us a bit but
that doesn't mean that other less
important characters are
safe in fact i think quite a few of them
are in serious danger
back inside shigaraki's mind all for one
seems to be winning the fight to control
shigaraki's body
he says that the fight between one for
all and all for one has already shed a
lot of useless blood
but what just happened to bakugo has to
be the most useless of all
when he hears this and when he thinks
about all the other people who suffered
during this fight deku snaps he knows
that keeping his cool and keeping his
head clear is the best way to control
his power
but he just can't help it after bakugo's
brave sacrifice
deku refuses to sit back and listen to
all for one disparaging his friend
deku goes full legendary super saiyan
mode and he rushes at shigaraki slash
all for one as we see a close-up of
shigaki's face it seems clear that all
for one
is the one in control and to make things
even creepier
all for one inside of shigaraki is
actually smirking
and this is the point at which the focus
of the chapter shifts to another
location so yes
it did happen but not at the very
beginning which is good
gigantomachia continues to rampage
through various cities on his way to
jakku
and as he moves he is now beginning to
pick up two different scents
and they somehow both belong to his
master this suggests that
makia is somehow able to detect the fact
that all for one has just taken over
shigaraki's
body that's interesting because i kind
of assumed that all for one had just
taken over shigaraki's consciousness
and of course consciousness doesn't have
its own scent
so theoretically machia shouldn't have
noticed a difference
but there might be something else going
on here after all we still don't know
the specifics of fujiko's procedure but
it is possible that the procedure
included some modifications that even
shigaraki wasn't aware of
and maybe it is one of these
modifications which allows
all for one to not only take over
shigaraki's mind but to also manifest
in physical form i don't know how this
would even work
but this brief moment in which makia
senses over one's presence
inside shigaraki is likely a clue about
an important reveal that will happen
in the coming chapters we should
definitely keep an eye on that
and on machia's reaction back in jakku
the hero students who have been helping
with evacuations are now fully aware of
the dire situation in which they find
themselves in
deku and the other heroes fighting
shigaraki don't even know that makia is
coming because remember shigaraki used
his quirks to jam
all the communication signals and so if
the other hero students don't
act now to help deku and the others and
to inform them about
gigantomachia shigaraki and makia will
join forces
and then the situation will be utterly
hopeless
as ochako wonders how deku bakugou and
shoto are doing
we suddenly switch focus back to the
main battlefield
shoto screams and in the very next panel
we see shigaraki
or i guess all for one within
shigaraki's body placing his hand
directly on deku's face all for once
says
i finally touched you now be mine
one for all suddenly deku or i guess his
consciousness
finds itself inside a strange and barren
place
but deku's body is not complete he looks
like he did
back in that strange vestige world in
chapter 193
except this time around more of his body
is
actually visible in chapter 193 it was
implied that deku's ability to access
and act within the vestige world
depended on the percentage of one for
all that he could actually use
so presumably now that he can use a
higher percentage of one for all
more of his body is visible inside the
vestige
world in the distance deku can see
shigaraki
and all for one shigaraki is doing his
best to resist
all for one and he's telling him to get
out and to not get any closer
but all for one insists that if he
hadn't lent him his power
shigaraki would have been burnt to a
crisp and died
shigaraki continues to resist and he
tells his mentor that he wants to
control his own body and follow his
own path but all for one seems
determined to remain in control of
shigaraki's body
the big question is whether this control
is only temporary
or whether all for one is attempting to
take over for good and maybe that was
his plan
all along the other thing that i'm
wondering is whether this is the real
all for one
or just some vestige or fragment of his
consciousness that was hidden away
inside the all for one quirk factor
maybe it doesn't matter because it
amounts to the same thing
but i'm very curious to know how exactly
all for one was able to orchestrate
this takeover if this really was all
part of his plan
how did he manage to split his
consciousness in a way that allows him
to exist in two places
at the same time inside his original
body in tartarus prison
and also inside shigaraki was this the
work of some sort of consciousness
copying quirk is this just how the all
for one quirk factor works
maybe it carries over vestiges of its
former user just like one for all does
there are so many intriguing questions
about what is happening to shigaraki
right now and if that's not enough deku
is now mixed up in all of this
as well while deku watches the struggle
between shigaraki and all for one unfold
he wants to do something but he can't on
the last page of the chapter we see
nana shimura as she touches the back of
deku's head
and tells him that he still can't move
in this world
but they will do something about that
and that is how this mind-boggling
chapter ends
and we are left with so many unanswered
questions and with so many possibilities
for what could happen next
i couldn't help but notice that nana had
also touched
the back of shigaraki's head in his own
dream world back when he first awoke
from his procedure
and now she touched deku in almost the
same way
but what is the significance of this and
by the way
what is this vestige world anyway is it
a dream world of sorts
is it a vision is it something between a
dream and a vision
is it the manifestation of the
consciousnesses of all of these
different people coming together
there are just so many unknowns i mean
it was one thing back when deku would
enter this world in order to communicate
with previous one for all users
we all just assumed that access to this
vestige world is a unique trait
possessed by a user of one for all
but then why did shigaraki enter a
similar world
back when he first woke up from the
procedure and how was
nana apparently able to enter
shigaraki's dream world
and also deku's vestige world and while
we're on the topic
why do deku shigaraki and all for one
all appear to be inside the same vestige
world
right now this is all very confusing and
mysterious but the main connection
appears to be
the two quirks one for all and all for
one
after all all for one was used to create
one for all in the first place
so perhaps the vestige world is not
unique only to one for all
perhaps the original vestige world stems
from all for one itself
and so now that he has come into direct
contact with all for one
deku is able to share this same world
with shigaraki all for one
nana and who knows who else i am sure
that in the coming chapters nana will
give us more crucial information
but the big question now is what happens
next is deku about to fight
all for one and shigaraki inside this
vested world
instead of in the outside physical world
and if so
how is deku going to fight when most of
his bodies still can't even manifest
inside this world is nana about to teach
deku to unlock
even more of one for all's power which
will theoretically give him full access
to this vested world
we definitely need more information
about the true nature of one for all
and all for one but i admit that i'm
intrigued
by this strange development what do you
guys think
what is this vestige world really and
how are deku and shigaraki able to enter
the same
one together and what does this crazy
development mean
for the rest of the story are we about
to witness an inner battle between one
for all and all for one
or is it going to stay on outward
physical battle or are we gonna get a
little bit of both
this is starting to remind me of the
demon king battle in the seven deadly
sins manga
but we'll wait and see where this thing
goes definitely leave your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video you want to see more
boku no hero content right here on the
channel
please drop a like to let me know it
really does help
thank you so much for 1 million
subscribers that is crazy
and if you're not one of our subscribers
yet please consider subscribing and
hitting that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one
possible a special thank you to alpha
sigma
and liam thompson disciples of lord
twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above
all other clans including ingrata
the world acquired respect pate heffa
jonathan king
rathuyin deora emperor otaku thomas
jones kin mano
admirath and chris torley finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including
the one and only gilgamesh nothing but a
fan king zeldris
anatoly kazatsky angel cruz cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
hinokamian water
bonnie parks jason wilson florian joy
and garcia
steelers mcshamus jessica kayla fond
deadly saint
stern hawkings and high school dxd73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you